this is the best curly haired teacher
she she's
she's giving me all the tips
and techniques
i needed this
hey guys my name is lisa torres from
brooklyn new york i'm a barber stylist
and today i'll be showing you how to get
a curly mohawk and look just like
lamella ball
so let's welcome our client for today
jay have a seat what's up what's up
so you ready you ready for your full
lamello skinfee mohawk i'm ready i'm
excited so yeah yeah this is 2017 la
mello right here i remember just boom
and he shaved it off so i heard his
father and his brother paid him to cut
his hair off what yup because they hated
his hair 2019 he brought the table back
see so that makes sense he took their
money he said i'm gonna grow my hair
right back and then boom then he brought
in like the curly mohawk 2019 2020 you
know the the mohawk is just getting
longer so what are you feeling if i was
to pick i'll get a mixture between like
this december 2021 and then this may
2021 well to be honest what is going to
really determine the style is going to
be where your curl and your coil is
actually strong because your hair is
yours and his asses
so now we know what we're ready to do we
are going to debunk the hair first we're
going to put in our clipper fade then we
are going to trim the long hair and
we're going to style it
i'm ready for you
[Music]
so when was your last haircut uh like
two years ago wow this is two years yeah
so i have a hair clip what i'm going to
do is i'm going to clip away the hair
that we are not going to use for our
clippers
so the first step we're going to match
this side to this other side when i'm
looking to match a mohawk you're always
going to stand in front of the person
and line up the line from the right side
to the left side you're constantly
looking for points on the person's head
to measure where to start and where to
end so for example behind his ear is
actually where we're looking to end it
so on this side i'm looking to aim
towards behind his ear so this looks
pretty even i'm going to start debulking
the hair with my wall magic clipper
one and a half guard you're actually
gonna go with the grain
first creating the blend from the side
of your head to the top of your head i
don't actually put it on the scalp at
first i get pretty close part of my life
just left me
so at this point um i see that he
doesn't have any light spots which
sometimes you can't see when the hair is
long and it's making me more confident
to actually go against the head as i go
down
and that's a perfect canvas now for when
we start our skin fade so we're going to
repeat the process and we're not going
to assume that he doesn't have any light
spots on this side now we're going to go
in and we're going to put in our skin
so i like to go in with a hard line and
what we're going to do is we're going to
start
mimicking the shape of the mohawk where
it starts off in the front and curls
into the back
we're gonna actually put the same line
on the other side so as we blend we have
a more consistent haircut on each side
now we're gonna go in with our super
close wall electric razor so with this
we're not gonna go um up as high because
that's gonna be our first level skin
[Music]
i'm just going to repeat it on the other
side
we already created the shortest length
so we're going to create the longest
length so now i'm going to do the one
and a half clip with the grain because
we're already committed to this area
so now we created our foundational
length we're going to go in no clipper
we're going to create our half this is
going to be our midway point
[Music]
it's very important to follow throughout
the entire haircut and keep it
consistent with the levels
now we're gonna mimic that on the other
side
okay so now we created our three levels
we're gonna blend in from the shortest
to the middle and then the middle to the
highest the idea of a fade
is for the hair to flawlessly go into
each other so i think where the head
starts to curve is always the hardest
we're going to go in and we're going to
start to blend the darker hair
[Music]
now i'm going to go in with the half
guard
and this will be the final step to bring
everything together
our
second step of the clipper fade is
finished but we're gonna also evaluate
your
curls you use the moroccan oil
how did you know about that because i
can smell it it smells so good
lgq moroccan oil know about
[Music]
so basically we're just cutting all the
dead ends
what's the best way to comb
through nappy head like mines one be
patient because a lot of times out of
frustration you start pulling through
the knots and then you break your hair
and you're actually creating more knots
in the future
two make sure your hair is wet and
conditioned and then you can go in and
start to detangle and always start from
the ends and work your way toward the
room
[Music]
what we'll do is when we make your curls
when we have your curls defined then
we'll go in and give what's considered
more like a curl cut like
cutting it while it's already styled
this is just to make all the hair even
so we're going to cut the back
[Music]
are you a little mellow fan seems like
it when i first heard of la mello he was
trending on twitter for dropping 99
points in a game wow yeah i was like who
is this kid and i've been i've been a
fan ever since
really matted like don't over commit to
using a comb see how i'm like using my
fingers to kind of like comb through
your hair
because combs can actually create uh
tighten the knots if it's too aggressive
we're just taking off like the obvious
hair we're not gonna use and then when
we style it we go back in we're gonna
like detail you where your curls really
need to be
so the thing about like repairing hair
is that you do have to understand the
result you want may not be straight out
of the chair but as long as you are
given like a routine to follow at home
your hair will reach
what you ultimately want it to look like
for people who are like growing their
hair from beginning i always try to
encourage to start all of that from the
beginning it's always easier to prevent
something than it is to try to fix it
[Music]
he had a little curly mullet back here
like it was like way longer
[Laughter]
[Music]
we just took out all of the hair that
was like obviously
too long
or too
damaged now we're going to wet the hair
we're going to drench it in water so we
can like reactivate the curls and then
we're gonna see from there
how we're gonna take the hairstyle so
let's uh walk on
over here to uh wet your hair and then
we'll be right back
right now i'm gonna put in oil first
because what i want to do is i want to
start styling it before we go in and
remove any more hair
just put some oil
what type of oil moroccan oil
[Music]
this is going to help with the combing
process because we added something to
smooth it and you always want to make
sure that whenever you put a product in
your hair you comb it through it's not
really evenly distributed until you kind
of comb it through i'm going to add in a
little bit of leave-in conditioner not
too much because you don't want to put
too many products in your hair so when
you're putting stuff into your hair you
kind of want to like section it and make
sure that you really thoroughly get it
into that section your curls are not
going to be as defined today as they
will be as when you start building your
curl memory meaning
scrunching
constantly like trying to scrunch your
hair until it's natural curl when you
dry your hair guys go like
don't do that
like just try to go like this
okay so this is pretty combed in
we're gonna go in and finger coil it so
that we can define his curls so you'll
just like grab a piece of hair
and kind of curl it like that like on
your own i like to use something that
has a stronger hold simply because my
curls kind of fall apart so right now
i'm just taking off any excess product
now we're gonna go in and we're going to
create some curls
[Music]
so this may be tedious but
this is the process to beginning like
that curl memory we're gonna see how
much your hair curls
well ultimately we might have to cut
some of these side curls since they're
looking pretty long
this is pretty much what amelo had when
he was doing like those tighter coils
they were all finger coils and you teach
me everything today
curly hair is like the most
misunderstood hair
so it's okay to make the curls kind of
big
it's just that when you dry it you can
break the curls down you just want to be
gentle about it it can be time consuming
to make it so you don't want to make
them so little that you're there all day
coiling
the biggest you should ever go is like
the size of your finger
so curls are best when they look random
so you just want to kind of grab pieces
as you see
so i kind of just coil it around my
finger and then i just slide my finger
off and then it should be
the average size curl because even if
his curls are tighter than this when we
break the curls after they're dry it'll
start to come out like his natural curl
size
lamella's hair mostly has curls on the
outside not so much like at the root of
it so this definitely works so this part
right here is the diffuser
the best way overall to dry your hair is
air drying in my opinion but a lot of
times we don't have time for that so you
want to use a low or medium heat with a
medium speed you don't want to put high
heat or high wind levels
to help like set it in this way where we
start to encourage curl patterns to come
back having a blow dryer and a diffuser
would really
help
because if you just went outside without
drying it it's very likely to fall but
if you dry it before you leave it'll
hold the form
sometimes you have to see what the hair
wants to do before you can commit to
cutting certain areas i didn't know how
short your hair was going to curl so i'd
rather leave it long and then we could
go back in and detail the silhouette
i pull the curl and i kind of like slide
down against the curl when the hair
coils the hair is like a lot longer than
what it really is so if you were to just
cut it bluntly and it jumps back up the
hair is not going to all be in the same
place so if you keep it coiled even if
you stretch it and you cut it kind of
like with the curl it'll still kind of
taper out into a little curl so yeah so
even though we blow-dried it with the
diffuser you're not really going to see
your final final result until it kind of
air dries but it's a good way to walk
out the door and not feel like you just
came out the shower
so i'm just gonna dry it a little bit
more
okay so i think that your hair is pretty
much done we're just gonna clean up your
beard and then we can look at your new
hairstyle
[Music]
okay
we are all done
[Music]
curls on deck curls on deck
okay okay
[Music]
i love it i love the curls i love the
mohawk love it i'm a deathly rocket new
york and now you know how to take care
of your hair for the future
and how to really get your curls popping
like mellow i think that's like the
biggest part
thank you for everything yeah of course